biden's
new lockdowns
that's the focus of tonight's angle
are we about to face another lockdown
another period of time where americans
feel like they can't travel they can't
even maybe go to work or see family well
not travel for pleasure anyway only for
essential activities
remember it was two years ago can you
believe it it was the coveted lockdowns
the foolish closures that had zero basis
in science
but today it's not a virus that may keep
us from jumping in our cars and doing
and going anywhere we want it's high gas
prices and inflation caused by joe
biden's suicidal green agenda
and like with covid they're asking you
to sacrifice for the greater good
americans agree that they are willing to
even sacrifice themselves by paying more
at the pump they're okay paying higher
prices if it means holding russia
accountable people
at the pump who maybe can't even afford
it saying it's okay though if i have to
pay more at the pump to help the
ukrainians
now this should be no surprise to any of
us because for decades washington has
been asking hard-working americans to
sacrifice for the politicians awful
policies so sacrifice for wars in the
middle east sacrifice because of the
housing crisis sacrifice for the
pandemic and now they're told to
sacrifice for ukraine and climate change
but the result's always the same
the government gets bigger spends more
while the middle class ends up poorer
and more despondent than they were
before
now i'm old enough to remember when
democrats used to believe and things
called hope and change
but now they pretty much dropped all
that
with democrats all they've done in to
derail america biden's long dark winter
is turning into a painful spring
and next he's going to bring us a
sweltering miserable summer and lord
knows how depressing a fall it's going
to be
this this war by putin is not going to
be costless it's not going to be
painless i think it's also true that the
world needs to be prepared for a very
long difficult road ahead there will be
cost as well here in the united states
you know what the truth is
they believe the planet cannot sustain
your standard of living and most
importantly
that you don't deserve your standard of
living
they think it's high time that you your
kids your grandkids
get used to living with less
this is all rerun of the 1970s when we
were told we had to drive more slowly we
had to turn our thermostats down in the
winter and up in the summer
and back then jimmy carter blamed the
energy crisis but remember there was no
energy crisis we had plenty of energy in
the 70s just like we have plenty of
energy now
this crisis is self-inflicted
created by leaders who seem to be
enjoying punishing americans instead of
serving them
and they certainly don't think that
the people deserve answers to any
questions about this any comment on
saudi arabia secretary
okay there you can ask me the question
the next meeting
secretary hi i'm the press secretary so
i can answer them
for more pipelines in the united states
to help with the energy crisis
she's the energy secretary and won't
answer questions about americans
concerns about energy think about that
for a minute
the biden is puppet masters are going to
use every bit of this russia ukraine
crisis to take your money and your
freedom
this is going to happen through another
massive expansion of government i
promise you
we're told now that we need to
immediately spend what 14 billion and
send that to ukraine
but who believes it's going to stop
there
americans will always rush in to help
those in need that's what makes us so
great we're so compassionate and we're
so generous and i know so many of you
are you're donating right now
but we cannot let this horrific tragedy
in ukraine allow us to forget what
matters most
preserving the american way of life
remember what the flight attendants say
before you take off secure your own
oxygen mask before attempting to help
others
yet the left hopes that americans i
think kind of give up and give in
and just accept a lower standard of
living the high gas prices are just
going to be that's the new normal it's
the cost of progress people
it's a new way to virtue signal living
with less
and sometimes not having children what
am i talking about well raymond arroyo
went out to talk with folks in virginia
today they're facing high gas prices
there we're going to show you more about
this later but listen to this i'm
grateful i can work from home i know i
have some you know friends who are
seeing if their job will let them work
from home maybe a couple more days a
week if not just to kind of figure out
those numbers you know i'm grateful i
don't have i don't have kids so changes
like this
the the marginal change it doesn't
affect me so much
wearing the mask outside is always a
tell well this is called conditioning
priming you to believe that the old way
the whole you know kids you know just
getting in your car and driving wherever
you want that was the wrong way you
selfish person if you're truly
compassionate you will tolerate and even
like high gas prices
because it'll help the ukrainians
there's an understanding of that this is
in essence a small price to pay
particularly if you look at what's going
on in ukraine and you put yourself in
their shoes that's a cost of defending
freedom
they want you to believe that this is
all inevitable the truth is it isn't
none of it ever was
three years ago we actually had a
president in power who showed us that
middle america is not consigned to
inevitable decline
wages were rising and so was optimism
but the globalists hated that they hated
the fact that wages were going up for
the blue-collar workers they had to dump
trump because he showed that informed
nationalism patriotic nationalism can
lead to more prosperity and more freedom
that's better lives for everybody who
wouldn't want that
this crowd that's who
to shape our common future in collective
and constructive ways the recovery
cannot be a mere restart the
reconstruction must be a transformation
every country city financial institution
and company
needs to adopt credible plans for
transition to net zero emissions by 2050
you give up your private jet first buddy
well biden is answering to these people
the globalists
the davos crowd not to you and your
concerns
not democracy it's not the american way
and it's not acceptable
this is our country it belongs to the
american people not international
bureaucrats
the salaries of every single person in
the biden administration are paid for by
you and by me
so going forward the key issue for every
voter should be this
who will put your interest first who's
going to work for you your family your
hopes your dreams
we know it's not biden in the democrats
but
i think they're on the way out i think
they know that the future belongs to
political leaders who help americans
triumph not delight in their suffering
and that's the angle